we are going to continue to fight and
want justice
[Music]
portia williams remains on the front
lines of the black lives matter movement
the real housewives of atlanta star was
arrested on tuesday during a peaceful
protest in louisville kentucky
in honor of brianna taylor
porsche was charged with obstructing a
highway and disorderly conduct in the
second degree
the reality star was arrested alongside
her friend lovin hip-hop new york star
yandy smith harris
[Music]
the two were protesting the death of the
26-year-old emt
who was fatally shot in her own home by
louisville metro police earlier this
year
though one officer was fired months
after the incident
none of the officers involved have been
arrested or charged
this is the second time porsha has been
arrested for peacefully protesting in
the name of brianna
in july the reality star was taken in
alongside 87
other protesters who had gathered
outside the home of kentucky attorney
general
daniel cameron i need to be with my
people
with our allies side by side
and fighting for real change and for the
other families who have
been victims of police brutality in june
porsche spoke with e.t about being moved
to protest in the wake of the death of
george floyd
it ignited what was in me to want to
fight for real change
but it has to be known that it has to be
demanded that we are able to peacefully
protest it is the voice of the people
the message that we have is not going to
die it's not
george flora will not have died in vain
brianna taylor will not have died in
vain
and the other people who have been
victims of police brutality will not
have died
in vain from the streets two billboards
and magazines
justice for briana taylor has in stock
the emt
graces the cover of vanity fair's
september issue
the feature tells the story of brianna's
life and death
through the eyes of her mother tamika
palmer for the first time in 20 years
oprah winfrey stepped off the cover of
her magazine to feature brianna
would you be content to hear five months
later
there's an investigation and that no one
has been held accountable for shooting
your
innocent daughter multiple times
and letting her life bleed out the media
mogul also paid for dozens of billboards
around louisville kentucky
in effort to amplify brianna's story and
to seek justice for her death
these 26 billboards won for
every year of brianna's life are my
offering
my form of protest we cannot
be silent we have to use whatever
megaphone we have
to cry for justice